Shawny it's lovely to see here at London
Film on comic-con it's been a busy old
day hasn't it it's really busy and it's
really hot and I feel like um you know
I'm in short sleeves but there's some
people walking around today in costumes
that are leather and stuck and there's
fur and the like I don't know how
they're doing it you know it's really
hot I can't believe this is London have
you done this event before I've not done
this event before it's the first London
convention first London comic-con so
yeah it's really cool because I'd only
done the one in in San Diego and I don't
know I dare say this is bigger like this
is huge
it's messy but I had no idea what to
expect so it's been a real pleasant
surprise and last time you say that we
were talking about an all-action
all-female movie that you're working on
a kind of kind of female Expendables if
you like and I wouldn't have what kind
of stage you're at with that because
everyone's kind of thinking call it this
sounds fantastic we want to say it is it
does sound good doesn't it would be good
if it sort of had another step I'm
honestly not sure with that one what's
happening I mean I really would love to
see it happen but I don't know any more
than the last time I spoke to you any
more about it but I'm still hopeful that
it can happen because like everyone else
I would really look forward to seeing a
all female Expendables sort of version
of the film and you know the male one
does so well why not do it with the
females just to clear it up because I
know there is kind of confusion out
there on the internet and fans of yours
might be a bit confused as well because
there's the movie that you are attached
to with Katee Sackhoff and gina carano
which is being called by people on the
internet kind of a female Expendables
but then there's also I guess the
franchise The Expendables with Sylvester
Stallone here also came along I said
we're working to make a movie now so
that there's that difference isn't that
it's just completely different really I
mean there's already obviously a male
Expendables so if that same production
company goes ahead and does a female
version that would be the female version
of the
spendables because that is their company
we never named our movie the female
Expendables that's just what the
depressive named it because you've got
three action women together and that's
what the movies looking like it's going
to roughly go towards is gearing towards
that scripts are completely different
would be a completely different film but
yeah I think just because it's a similar
idea of getting women together and and
and the fact that so I actually has the
franchise and we would be a completely
different cast and a different script
and a different story and completely
different action and yeah it would be
like night and day the film's so I think
it's just getting lost in in in the
wording of the female Expendables which
is not the name of the movie the movie
have a title you know I don't believe it
does the untitled Adi Shankar project
yeah I mean if you could have anything
happen in that what would you like to
see you three guys and whoever else
comes up were doing in that movie doing
oh man I just think it would be really
interesting because we all really like
we really come from different
backgrounds and our strengths even
though we're all very much action women
our strengths like completely in
different parts of action you know I
mean I mean Gina does what Gina does you
know and I don't do that at all like she
is so strong and she's so coming from
that world of fighting and I don't come
from that world I come from a ballerina
world so I come from a dancing world and
like sort of Jack be nimble Jack be
quick is how I would picture my like
whip it snippet character you know she's
fast and she's nimble and she's just
sort of here there and everywhere and
that girls like the strength and then
Katy would be what Katy does you know
maybe with weapons or something or you
know I just think that it can take on
you've got similar action women but
they're nothing the same so it's
actually really interesting what would
happen when they combine forces yeah
can't wait this happen
now you mentioned Patrick of course as
well and in that
you were starting with Charles stunts
who is in Game of Thrones I mean what
was it like to work with trial stunts on
that it was insane I have like a
confession in that I had not watched
Game of Thrones when I actually met so
dance and but like that doesn't mean I
didn't know who he was I was very aware
and it was quite intimidating at first
because to be honest that man walks into
a room and he's like royalty he doesn't
mean to be he just is he's just got this
presence and he's so warm and
charismatic but at the same time like
like you just we just lost anymore most
like because he just carries himself so
well and he's such a nice person and so
down to earth but it was kind of cool
because my character and Patrick had to
be a little bit intimidated and wary of
the doctor and that's kind of at first
the reaction that I had with gels and so
you know he came up and kissed me on the
forehead the first day and I was like
all right I'm gonna get kisses from
Charles every day on the forehead it's
okay it's fine I love this job he's not
just sweet man you know and he plays the
villain so well he's nothing like it so
just like a dream come true to work with
him you know it was a real honor
actually to be at stitches last year in
Spain and to have Patrick screen and
then to also be there with Charles while
he accepted his you know honorary
Lifetime Achievement Award and I
actually walked down the auditorium and
I didn't know this was coming but we all
walked down the auditorium to go onto
the stage and he put his arm out like
that and I hooked my arm in I felt like
I was at my damn wedding it was
incredible I was like well look at the
respect that you get when you're on the
arm of a man like that never felt
anything like it it was just incredible
like all the reaction from this
auditorium the reception that he gets is
it's utmost respect first and it was
just amazing just to be around him is so
great you know I'm what we look forward
to nights from you Johnny I actually
just shot a film in China with Jackie
Chan yeah you might have the first scoop
on that one but yeah it's it was amazing
Jackie Chan's been an idol of mine Oh
forever you know and what was actually
even more amazing was to meet him in
person and he's actually even more of an
inspiration and a hero
off screen than he is on which says a
lot because he can't get bigger but he's
just so devoted to his charities and you
know to giving back and that's really
what hee hee is all about and he does it
on his own dime and in his own time and
when he's not shooting that's what he's
doing and the videos that he's put
together of how he really is changing
the world and inspiring these kids to
make their dreams come true and and the
happiness that it's providing them is
just that's the idol that is Jackie Chan
so yeah it was a real pleasure I didn't
actually get to shoot a scene with him
I'm only in a very small part of the of
the film but you know I got to act
opposite John Cusack and Adrien Brody so
you can't ask for like Charles dance you
know I'm just working with incredible
people at the moment so I couldn't be
more blessed really and what's the name
of the film sweet account for it dragon
blades comes out the Chinese New Year
first day in February next year
it's an action epic adventure picture
Jackie Chan in his element at John
Cusack - the mixes is as his sidekick
hero and then add Adrien Brody as the
villain
I'm the queen of the Roman Empire it's
it's it's a it's an epic it's a typical
Jackie epic you know and I think I
believe it's the highest budget Chinese
film ever
to date so hopefully it's gonna pay off
it like being involved in that I've
never in my life been involved with a
production that was that budget you know
and it's interesting because you're next
to this day is my most rewarding film
that I've ever done that was a half a
million dollar budget so it really does
go to show you that it's just got
nothing to do with I don't think money
it's quality of product and you can make
that on a low dime you can make it on a
high dime but it's the people that
you're working with it's the director
it's the actors you know and this was
such a huge budget it was just crazy to
be on this certainties to see what
really happens when money money comes
into play you know because we lived in a
trailer pretty much for your next I
loved him and loved it but then you step
onto this set and it's handy and world
studios and it's just absolutely
mind-blowing it's like wow this is its
it you know and there's horses
everywhere and it's beautiful if the
little taste of what your characters
about I'm really in the film it's all
about the guys you know I'm very very
small part in the film probably only
five to ten minutes of the film
I played the Queen of the Roman Empire
the film shot in 48 BC and it's set
during the Han Dynasty so it's all about
the Silk Road and you'll see me in
flashbacks in a very difficult love sort
of forbidden love
you know with John Cusack's character
yeah she's he's a warrior and I'm the
queen and it's forbidden so yeah there's
a bit of pain behind the Queen and I had
to learn how to play the harp yes that
was tough in a day yes my teacher said
she had ten years lessons to learn how
to play the harp and I had three hours
so I will see how good that looks
see if I pulled that one off we'll see
yeah Johnny it's been levy talking to
you as always thanks so much you talk
thank you so much
you